[Music]
in safe secret news submitted by in the
morning he was throwing dice yeah here's
how you can share other people's secrets
without ruining their lives secrets
secret Souls never ever secrets everyone
[ __ ] tells everybody everything right
if you tell someone something they're
gonna tell us gonna tell at least one
person is there an app that says like
how people really are in relationships
and not [ __ ] I could like an
anonymous yelp app for relationships
like a review I should make one right so
it's like hey here's how this chick is
dude it's like I know she's cute and all
the [ __ ] but like she's [ __ ] believe
it
well it has to be after a certain amount
of time I give me like three years and I
don't mean persons gonna be a different
person violence but I'd like to know if
she would burn my car down or not but
tip what if there's like 3000 reviews
isn't that kind of nice we could
guarantee by the three five-star three
thousand five sites that's good yeah so
if her dick sucking quality was bad by
the first review you know by three
thousand she probably is pretty good now
that would be helpful for the girl so
she could improve I think so isn't that
what a girl wants an awesome and
honestly like guys knew that the most
cuz they need improvement at one in a
lot of areas anticipation makes guys
know challenging make it interesting
yeah you don't want a boring lecture
yeah what would you do anyway so uh
we're talking about secrets here that uh
this professor of leadership and ethics
at Columbia Business School who studies
the psychology of Secrets said that the
reason why people share secrets is
because they don't want to be lonely so
they don't want to be the only person
alone with the thoughts of the secret
that's being shared with them and so
that's why some people just feel like
they really can't keep a secret and they
just have to tell someone else and it's
because of the fact and they're not
loyal
well isn't the person who tells the
secret can they also can't keep a secret
because they can't keep their own secret
well is unless it comes from the source
if you're gossiping telling someone
else's you hold to yourself telling
someone else's secret that's when is
disloyal
well it's such a relief to be able to
say like oh my god I finally told
someone empty bottles yeah
it's therapeutic because they might go
can I see it but it's therapeutic but
the same way it's therapeutic for that
other person to tell someone else that
you have two buckles because I tells me
a super ho there's no way as soon as I
get in the car I guess when he poops if
it's split it's like a little song in
there something like have you ever told
a secret and like felt bad afterwards so
it's all someone else's secret yeah yeah
I really tough yeah I'm trying to think
I don't really well somebody telling me
I kind of try to forget it
yeah but have you forgotten it so hard
that you forgot it was a secret and then
you tell it hold her a guy that's who
you want to see to it that okay I'll
take it to the grave with me if you can
remember yeah or else I'm telling it
when you're in the heat of the moment
you're just having a conversation you're
like oh wait this person doesn't know
this stuff when he squirrel Game of
Thrones to me yeah so I was in the heat
at the moment itself to share a secret
so you don't feel alone but not hurt or
ruin other people's live especially the
person who gave you the secret or
whatever they're suggesting that you
have to find an impartial audience so
you have to find someone who is not who
does not know the person that you're
talking about the secret like that is
involved in the secret at all
a therapist or account like some sort of
counselor
a religious leader would be like the
best person no no the person unless you
live in a small town that's not a good
idea
the first two were fine imagine laying
on my therapist cast on me just you told
me also to keep that information to
myself if that interesting it's so
interesting they never get pissed at the
person who told you the secret like
after you hear you're like [ __ ] why did
you tell me no I'm a part of the
conspiracy
yeah [ __ ] man if it's about somebody
that you know it's I thought I didn't
want to know that now I gotta I'm gonna
be thinking about this so that's him
that's the first thing I'm banging and
it leads to 100 more questions like I
watched a Diane Sawyer thing with
Christopher Reeves years ago and he's in
the will train he's like oh yeah his
wife's like oh yeah we still have sex
and I'm like how this opens all the
questions I want to know how they do it
like this let's talk about it I heard I
heard he was kind of a big if you say
like fingers then it's like oh come on
man you just calling this sex right yeah
it's not even like inquiring minds want
to know yeah yeah well it's like that
game there was in elementary school you
know we go around you tell almost I
forgot what it's called like I tell him
something
telephone yeah tell you so like it never
comes back around the same why is that
so hard it's like well add their own
twist to it because people that did his
their MRIs other people's secrets and
put it to put the two together or
whatever yeah yeah they'll actually
receive the information but not receive
it as it's given and it's like a
different language in their head so they
end up like twisting it because that's
the way they thought that they heard it
but he tells me that he has two
buttholes I'm like yeah he has two
troubles so there's a story that one of
my old employees at the gym
told told us where he got into a fight
with his sister when he was in I don't
know like elementary school and so he
wanted to punch his sister but he's like
houston she's a girl so I'm hitting my
and he punched over the left hand now
this is maybe like four or five years
later and I hear the same story told
back to me from someone else and then
they're like I can't believe you had a
employee that hits women I'm like what
the [ __ ] that's not the context yeah
this person is not a woman beater this
is just a story from long time ago here
but in kids you it's crazy how I go
through and it turns into some other and
now this person has this person as a
different label and reputation that's
the bad thing about a lot you didn't
[ __ ] around and tell the wrong Seger to
tell so and then now this whole person
has a whole nother idea about this
person I just got in a fistfight with my
sister in like third grade people are
like oh that guy's a [ __ ] wife beater
like have you ever had somebody tell you
a secret that you already knew though
like I'm gonna pretend like you didn't
know I had a buddy come up I come out to
me I'm great at that oh yeah you know
I'm gay I'm like oh my god I can't wait
till the day that someone that I
suspected was gay if someone that I
suspected that was gay came out and said
they're gay I can't wait till the day
that that happened so I could be like I
knew it yeah because there's a few
people that I always thought they were
gay but they're straight and I'm just
still waiting for the day that build up
like hey can I talk to you what days
good for you all this an ego you sit
down and I already know you're gay it's
fine you know everybody says it I'm like
oh wow like I don't want to be a
[ __ ] to be like yeah the party yeah
[ __ ] again like would that be a bad
thing though cuz maybe I mean depends on
the person but maybe they could take it
as like oh she knew this whole time okay
good
oh my gosh I didn't have to hide it like
like we were waiting for you to come out
we all we all knew okay I like that
viral note that's his dad wrote to his
son because I guess in the note he says
like I overheard you talking to so once
a twitch is his boyfriend
and like you honestly don't need to come
out and do nothing if anything you need
to go out and get some milk because
we're out of milk and like I don't know
it was really loving though the way he
was like we've known since you were like
four you make your gay son get milk I
get the joke man
that's homophobic I know you're in there
you know second big but we need some
more milk anyway back to the secret
thing here so there's another suggestion
is consider waiting it out so once you
hear the secret and you want to tell
someone consider waiting a few days or
even a few hours to see if you still
feel the itch to gossip after the
initial excitement has worn away yes he
told me he has two buttholes four hours
later I'm in bed at night it's not about
the time it's about who I'm around
because if it's someone who knows them
too like I couldn't I could be by myself
at tummy a secret I'll go by myself for
a month I was a tiny one but then as
soon as I see wrong hey I just wanna
know if one bar holds burden the other
that's there it just then I think I'm
done yeah but then you know what do you
give a Musleh cookie and now I wanna
know why he wants to fart out of toe
there's another until there's another
secret that comes out and I'm like okay
then you're like oh this guy take two
dudes in the back right
I'm buddy no yeah it's fine the butthole
stuff that's more different okay that's
cool I love you that was cool hold on I
tell me I love you have you ever thought
about surgically opening it
one big it's like you're gonna have a
list of quit so if I tell you see girl I
have I have so many questions we gotta
sit down sorry Born This Way secret from
like a rumor like someone else told you
and then you're like oh [ __ ] I need to
know more and a curiosity kills you and
you have to go directly to the source
but you got to finesse it out of them
you want them to feel comfortable that
shit's - it's hard man like raise like
when I go to the bathroom just like
shitness it's kind of like it's been
smooth lately for me like you you've
been having good [ __ ] all right
maybe you know where this maybe it takes
a village to keep a secret maybe we all
be friends
a friendship support group but we leave
the butthole person out of it and we'll
just like ya know who do you think
happens you know each other
hundred people we will just do this for
a couple years until it's out of our
system the 25th year anniversary and
we're like wow we really did stretch
this out I love all of you my family
you're like that's what happens though
the secret guy tells someone and then
like now a whole group of people know
and then the whole goo if you would like
they can talk about the secret you know
they're like no you go ask them no you
go you're the closest one get more
information yeah [ __ ] it I'll ask over
then the one guy goes and he comes back
to us yeah so it is one bigger than the
other
[Music]